hey what's up guys my name is shono
there's no easy way to say this but
i'm starting a podcast okay so um this
is basically a little announcement video
uh featuring my cat as well here just to
let you guys know that i thought it'd be
a pretty cool idea to start a podcast
to do with like programming and game
development game engine development
life you know the the usual topics
everyone's doing podcasts these days
i uh i feel like if you're driving
somewhere long distance having my voice
in your car
you know would be pretty cool no but all
jokes aside a podcast is something that
i've been wanting to do for a while and
i finally
finally decided to find the time to
actually do it it's gonna be called the
channel podcast
um i very very little experience in
doing podcast i've never done a podcast
before so this is going to be
we're going to see what happens here but
basically it's not going to just be
me at least my goal is going to be to
have a guest on every episode of the
podcast and in fact
we've got a guest for the first episode
podcast itself will be live streamed on
my twitch channel there'll be a link in
the description below and the first
episode is going to go live
tomorrow at around 8 30 p.m australian
eastern standard time actually if you go
to twitch or tv slash the channel
schedule again there'll be a link in
description below you'll be able to see
when it's scheduled and what time that
will be in your time zone
if you wish to catch it live and i think
it'll be pretty cool to catch it live
because i will be
you know interacting with the chat chat
can ask questions we can talk about
some of the topics potentially the chat
gives us so if you want to be kind of
you know part of the whole experience
then definitely try and catch
that live now when the podcast finishes
in the next few days i'm going to be
distributing it to other platforms such
as youtube
spotify probably you know that kind of
stuff so you'll be able to catch it
you know if you miss a live stream don't
worry you'll still be able to listen to
the podcast of course it's not a live
only podcast that would be weird anyway
i hope you guys will enjoy this new
project of mine and in fact this first
episode i think is going to be really
interesting for those of you who are
interested in programming which to be
honest should be like most of you
watching this channel so me saying
goodbye didn't
record in the original video so i'm
recording it now i just couldn't
couldn't leave that out hope to see you
guys there tv slash the channel
goodbye have a good day